now if you're looking for something new
to read on the beach or wherever you're
relaxing this summer we have some
recommendations for you amazon books
editorial director sarah gilman is here
how are you doing good morning great how
are you all right so let's jump right
into it first up there's a book that you
say is a bit of a rom-com a bit of a
rom-com who doesn't love a rom-com right
everybody does right so people love to
read romances when they're on vacation
it's and this book thank you for
listening julia whalen is sort of
perfect for the romance curious out
there it's not threatening there's no
bodice ripping i mean look at the jacket
it's very friendly
but it's actually written by it's a
rom-com and it's written by
a
a real-life audiobook narrator who's
very well known and it's an insider's
look into the voice actors that are
bringing your favorite books to life and
it's set alongside a romantic plot but
it also pokes fun at all the romance
tropes so to me this book is perfect for
people who love books about books like
emily henry's book lovers
i like how you say romance curious don't
you like that romance
i like you get it you're like just want
to put your toe in so barack obama also
released his book list yesterday too and
now you've released yours so you're
giving people there's lots to choose yes
i know it's i don't know whose they're
going to go to but thank you for having
me on we're so glad you're here so next
up you have a thriller for people who
want some page turning action yes this
is things we do in the dark by jennifer
hillier
this is my pick for the thriller of the
summer i love this book so literally the
first page starts a woman is woken up by
the police she's next to her murdered
celebrity husband she looks down she's
holding a bloody razor and she has no
idea what happened and this is it kicks
off it is like a roller coaster of a
book literally like you're like whipping
around twists and turns and you get off
at the end you're like a little dizzy
but also you had a great time i've been
hearing about this book that's getting
popular on tick tock yes which one is
that it's called every summer after by
carly fortune this is for me my kind of
summer bee treat
i read this book i fell in love from the
very first line and if i had the luxury
i would have sat down and read it all in
one day i was totally hooked it's this
bittersweet love story about it's about
first love it's about soul mates it's
got a little bit of heat thrown in it's
sort of like a in between a pg-13 and an
r it's just enough it's your style of
books that you like to read
what are you saying like a little spice
i like a romance okay
every book seems so appealing there's
one you said a non-fiction option for
people who want to learn something new
on vacation i'm going on vacation next
week i hope i'm at a beach somewhere but
do i want to learn something new on
vacation what do you recommend i love to
read fiction on vacation some people
love to learn new things so i threw in a
non-fiction for them the last resort by
sarah stedola so this is a book that's
all about the history and the culture
behind beach vacations dating all the
way back to monte carlo and how that was
meant to be a real beach resort and it
also looks at the effect that climate
change is having on these places that we
go to like escape the cares of the world
but it's very real and i feel like
there's something very meta about
reading about the beach while you're at
the beach most people when they read
they're like i want to learn something
new i want to be a little bit smarter
after i put this down or they want a
little romance or spice
no judgment no judgment not be treated
okay good good good
you so you have another book lets
readers travel overseas without ever
leaving the chair yes this could be good
for a lot of people delaware's destiny
by tomi abaro first of all the jacket on
this book is so beautiful and evocative
and this is a book about three female
friends who come together after 30 years
for the wedding of one of their
daughters in nigeria
oh wow all right um so what about
a book that makes people feel better
about their crazy family okay vacation
land by meg mitchell moore so the jacket
on this book it's a beach and you kind
of get the sense it's going to be all
kind of like beachy days this is
actually family dysfunction but make it
beachy it's going to make you feel a lot
better about your own family ah well we
like that i love it when you come
because you make me want every book but
i'm i'm going to take this take a
vacation yes
thank you very much